we got our hands on sifu slow clap's
highly anticipated kung fu fighting game
with the sweet twist of death being a
core element of the gameplay if you want
to see straight gameplay consider
checking out our no death gameplay run
of the preview build on our youtube
channel hit that like sub to the channel
and tell me in the comments if you are
ready to get hyped let's get it
for those wondering where the title
comes from sifu is a chinese honorific
meaning master much like the more
well-known sensei from japanese culture
it's a fitting name for developer slo
clap's upcoming beat em up not just
because of the game's kung fu stylings
but also because sifu demands a mastery
of its combat if you're to have any hope
of reaching its conclusion at least that
is the impression that i took away after
playing the demanding brawler for the
first time the hands-on preview build we
were given only features a small slice
of what's to come when the full game
releases in february yet this is still
more than enough to showcase the depth
and potential brilliance of sifu's
hand-to-hand action
a back alley nightclub provides the
setting for the single level preview its
ambience shifting as you move between
neon lit social areas and dim backstage
corridors a thumping soundtrack emanates
from the pulsating dj booth position at
the head of the dance floor while a
secret fight club is tucked away in the
basement for those with exclusive access
i swiftly dispatch the lone bouncer on
the door with a few incisive strikes but
things aren't quite as smooth once i
descend into the club's busy underbelly
much like the martial arts movies that
inspired it sifu often positions you as
a lone fighter facing off against an
overwhelming number of foes this is the
case in most games of course and at
first glance the setup for sifu's brawls
look reminiscent of the batman arkham
games
the similarities basically end there
though sifu's combat is grounded in
reality you'll barely scrape by in most
encounters even when utilizing the full
potential of your fighting skills
awareness of the environment and
ingenuity this all begins and ends with
the martial art of pacmae an aggressive
style of kung fu that's adopted by
sifu's protagonist slow clap has its own
pacmay expert and fight choreographer
benjamin calusi who spent his youth
practicing the style under a chinese
master before opening his own martial
arts school in paris while some styles
of kung fu are designed for show pacmay
is focused on putting your attacker on
the ground and ensuring that they stay
there this is evident after a few short
minutes with sifu as its lightning fast
strikes connect with wince inducing
ferocity
it's not overly flashy but the sense of
impact behind each animation effectively
conveys how dangerous pacma can be in
the right hands devastating flurries are
seamlessly chained together flowing
naturally into parries and throws while
contextual actions turn the environment
into more than just a simple backdrop
for kung fu action being aware of your
surroundings is a key aspect to
surviving sifu's punishing fisticuffs
you might hop over a couch to create
separation or isolate a single enemy
scale a nearby wall to reach the
mezzanine and engage your foes from the
top of the staircase or launch an
unfortunate soul through a partition
before using a broken piece of its wood
as a makeshift weapon each fight feels
unique due to the layout and placement
of different objects and that's just
taking into account a single level glass
bottles are a frequent and easily
accessible weapon in the nightclub and
sweeping an enemy off their feet by
kicking an ottoman towards them will
never not be fun it's exciting to know
that these options will only expand in
the full game as the locations change
being able to shift the balance of power
by making smart use of what's around you
is inherently gratifying
when it comes to defense sifu uses a
familiar stamina system known as
structure this works a lot like sekiro's
posture where blocking too many attacks
in succession will leave you stunned
just long enough for the enemies to
capitalize on your mistake mixing
blocking with dodges and parries is
essential but only certain attacks can
be followed up with a rapid counter this
forces you to learn each enemy type's
move sets in an attempt to anticipate
what's coming you'll be facing off the
same opponents time and time again after
all aside from being punishingly
difficult sifu also dips its toes into
rogue-like territory there aren't any
random elements so it's not traditional
of the genre and the latest preview
build is focused on combat so it is
tough to gauge how these other systems
coalesce sifu's unique approach to death
is felt throughout however as each time
you die you're able to get straight back
up thanks to a magic pendant the only
caveat is that each time you do so the
pendant adds more years to your life you
might begin the game as a fresh-faced 20
year old but you'll quickly grow older
as your health bar trickles away during
my first run i hit the ripe old age of
32 before reaching the end while other
runs concluded with vastly different
ages aside from altering your appearance
getting older has some significant
gameplay implications too by advancing
in years you're able to deal more damage
yet you are also unable to sustain as
much the idea being that it takes years
to master kung fu so age comes with
experience and improved proficiency but
it also comes with brittle bones and
that introduces a weakness that wasn't
present in your youth slow clep says
there will be story connotations related
to your rapid aging and the price of
vengeance but this isn't present in the
preview build instead this snapshot of
the game offers a brief glimpse of the
intriguing elements wrapped around its
rousing combat my anticipation for
seafood was already high just based on
its trailers but after getting a taste i
can't wait for more see if it releases
on february 22nd 2022 for ps4 ps5 and pc
alright without further ado i'll send
you guys off with some more gameplay of
sifu enjoy
[Music]
do
that's closed tonight
no way
come on chad kick his ass i got a [ __ ]
ton of money riding on you
what the hell's going on
[Music]
oh
you